[Music]
foreign
[Music]
are you looking for an easy way to
expand your security delivery while
reducing your operational overhead and
increasing visibility across your
security infrastructure welcome back to
our go deep with Google Cloud Armor
Series where we do demonstrations on
capabilities and features so you learn
what's available how to use it and how
you can leverage it in your environment
in our previous video we covered
monitoring and dashboarding to make sure
Google Cloud armor is properly
protecting your organization
now we'll demonstrate how to keep your
organization even safer with
infrastructure as code IAC Automation
and security operations or secops
Integrations with third-party tools
check out the link in the description to
see the other videos in our series
playlist
Automation and integration with your
broader secops framework are
indispensable tools to have when
creating a unified security approach
they help decrease operational overhead
and allow for increased visibility
across the different aspects of your
security posture
Google Cloud armor configuration and
implementation can be automated in many
ways leveraging command line tools and
rest apis plus just like Google cloud is
built for partners Cloud armor provides
seamless Integrations with many
third-party vendor tools
for this video we'll cover how to use
infrastructure as code automation with
terraform to seamlessly perform actions
in Cloud armor integrating with a tool
to publish information and alerts
through different channels for greater
visibility in this case we'll use slack
and we'll do an overview of integrating
with a Sim tool to gain visibility for
cloud armor events within your
organization's secops systems
check out the description for the timing
of each of these so you can go to
whichever one you want at any point
let's get into it
for this first demonstration we'll show
the use of terraform as a way to manage
your Cloud armor deployments terraform
is an open source software tool that
lets you create and manage your virtual
and Cloud infrastructure such as the
rest apis for cloud armor through code
instead of manually this pattern is also
known as infrastructure as code IAC you
can set up terraform code for cloud
Armor security policies once and
automate the deployment of the right
policy quickly and easily when you need
it like when you're under attack
and you don't need to worry about the
specifics of cloud armor itself you can
use the terraform language you may
already be familiar with and maybe even
use with other parts of your Cloud
networking and security infrastructure
this provides a seamless way to perform
actions in Cloud armor without having to
use the UI and to even be able to
automate those actions we'll be
leveraging the terraform provider to
automate the deployment of policy and
rules you can check out the link in the
description for the terraform provider
for the demonstration we'll show how to
deploy the web application firewall WAFF
update the configuration and rules and
align WAFF updates with their existing
pipelines all using terraform
to begin we'll start in the console and
open Google Cloud shell and then the
editor
here I've prepared a terraform script
that was built out for a new Cloud armor
policy you can check the link in the
description to see the GitHub repo where
this came from so now I'll open the
terminal again
and initiate a terraform plan using the
command terraform plan
it'll recap everything in the terraform
and I'll apply this new policy using the
terraform apply command and type yes
when I'm asked if I'm sure I want to
perform these actions it'll take a bit
for this to go deploy
now if we go into our Cloud armor portal
you may have to refresh the page if you
already had it open
we'll see the new infrastructure as code
security policy that we just deployed
using terraform now we'll look at how to
add another rule using terraform
Google creates pre-configured WAFF rules
for some types of vulnerabilities and
you can easily deploy them through your
tarot form so again I'll open up the
editor where I have that pre-deployed
terraform plan and I'm going to add a
pre-configured Waf rule for this and
save it
then I'll reopen the cloud shell
terminal
and use the terraform plan command
and then terraform apply to deploy the
change to the rule
once the rule is deployed we can again
go to the cloud armor section of the
Google Cloud console UI
click on the policy we've been
manipulating and we can see the new Waf
rule has been inserted into our policy
that's how easy it is to use terraform
to complete actions in Cloud armor if
you're not using terraform all of these
Cloud armor features we showed can also
be set up modified and edited using our
rest apis either directly or through
some other automation framework
for our next demonstration we'll show
how to configure the weft to integrate
with a monitoring and notification tool
within our Google Cloud environment we
have the ability to push information
through multiple channels like mobile
devices pagerduty slack web hooks emails
SMS and a pub sub Channel
for the purposes of our demo today we'll
start by setting up a notification
channel to Slack
let's go to Cloud monitoring
and click on alerting in the left hand
pane then click on edit notification
channels
scroll down to the slack integration
click on add new and it'll redirect you
to authenticate with Slack
once authenticated enter the name of the
slack Channel and provide a display name
for the alert
you can optionally test that the
integration is working by clicking on
send test notification
now we've connected our alerting system
into a slack Channel where we can send
alerts from the PHP rules that we
created in one of our previous videos
configuring rules and policies
let's get into integrating with the tool
itself
to begin let's go to Cloud logging
and enter the query to filter to the log
lines that correspond to requests with
PHP vulnerability and click on run query
now let's create an alert for when Cloud
armor detects PHP vulnerabilities
to do that click on create alert
provide a name for the alert policy
let's call it PHP alert
you can optionally include documentation
for example playbooks that should be
leveraged by your teams when they
receive this alert
click next and note that the query we
initially entered in Cloud logging is
populated under log to include
we set the notification frequency and
Auto close duration and click next
for notification select the slack
Channel we created and optionally email
as well click save and we've created our
alerting policy
and if we go into our slack Channel you
can see that the alert was triggered for
a PHP vulnerability that I simulated in
the background
for our final piece we'll show an
overview of how we can integrate with a
Sim tool as in our previous video
monitoring and dashboarding where we use
the log data sync to create dashboards
and looker we'll need a log data sync to
connect our data to the Sim tool as a
refresher options for data sync
destinations are many including Cloud
logging buckets bigquery storage buckets
Pub sub topics integration into Splunk
via Pub sub or the rest apis integration
to Google Cloud Chronicle or a
third-party Sim tool
in this case we would choose a pub sub
topic as our data sync destination
once we create the sync it'll show up in
our log router and we can now use it to
integrate with a Sim type tool
for more information refer to the link
in the description that walks you
through how to do the end-to-end
integration with Sim tools using Pub sub
and dataflow IAC Automation and
integration with different setups tools
helps provide a holistic view of your
organization's information security and
increases the reach of your security
policies all while decreasing
operational overhead and increasing
visibility so you can rest easy and know
that your business is protected are you
using Cloud armor with any third-party
secops tools let us know in the comments
make sure to check out the links in the
description for helpful information and
if you found the demonstrations in this
video helpful make sure to subscribe so
you don't miss any of the upcoming
videos in our go deep with Cloud Armor
Series wait what there's more yes
there's more even though we've reached
the end of this first phase of the
series there is more to come so stick
around for the next phase of the series
to go even deeper with Google Cloud
armor and as always thanks for watching
[Music]